ça récolte dans les outre-mer dans les
deux rapporteurs sont nos collègues
vivaient de Lopez est un nouveau médecin
la délégation sénatale outre-mer reçoit
ce matin le président intercaut
outre-mer monsieur Maurice Gironcel qui
est accompagné de Madame Liliane Salomé
vice-président monsieur Gilles leperrier
médiateur de cabinet Monsieur Philippe
Schmitt expert président gurva demain et
Madame Caroline punisse juriste en scène
collaboratrice d'intercaux outre-mer
merci à tous pour votre présence et
votre disponibilité monsieur le
Président vous êtes venu me présenter en
février dernier les rapports sur l'enjeu
foncier outre-mer j'avais été frappé par
la convergence de nos de nos vues et de
nos analyses en particulier sur le fait
que la question foncière est absolument
centrale pour l'avenir de nos
territoires ultramarins
dans votre rapport vous présentez une
plateforme une quarantaine de
propositions qui témoignent de l'ampleur
de vos réflexions dans ce domaine au
cœur de celle-ci on trouve évidemment la
question du désordre foncier du
règlement du problème majeur des
indivisions la loi les chimie de 2018
que nous avons d'ailleurs encore évoqué
cette semaine
qui a représenté un progrès salué encore
récemment lors d'un colloque organisé
par le Conseil supérieur du notariat que
nous avons entendu également
mardi dernier plusieurs représentants
semble-t-il doit être encore
perfectionné nous serons très attentifs
à vos suggestions bien évidemment sur ce
sujet qui requiert une forte et urgence
mobilisation comme vous le savez notre
délégation c'est depuis longtemps saisi
de ce sujet et à réaliser trois rapports
conduits par notre collègue famille
portant respectivement sur le domaine
foncier de l'État la sécurisation des
droits fonciers et les conflits d'usage
dans les outre-mer
il est resté donc à étudier dans notre
point de vue le foncier agricole c'est
donc chose faite c'est en cours en
l'occurrence et comme vous nous
interrogeons sur les instruments de
protection et de reconquête des terres à
mobilisés le grignotage des surfaces
agricoles utiles est un phénomène qui
non seulement progresse mais ça
s'accélère dangereusement à l'exception
de la Guyane
laquelle a aussi d'immenses défis à
relever par ailleurs cette étude nous
amène à questionner l'objectif
gouvernemental d'autonomie alimentaire
d'ici 2030 pour les outre-mer nouveau
félicitons donc de l'échange de cette
matinée ne rapporteur vous ont adressé
une trame de questions sur laquelle vous
pourrez accès aux propos liminaires vous
les personnes qui vous accompagnent
d'ailleurs je vous laisse le soin de
distribuer la parole au sein de votre
délégation en fonction des sujets que
vous souhaiterez aborder et puis après
je donnerai évidemment la parole à nos
deux rapporteurs et à nos collègues qui
sont au présent ou à distance monsieur
le Président vous avez la parole ça
marche vraiment merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices de
nous recevoir Monsieur le Président
effectivement donc on s'était rencontré
en février dernier et nous avons donc
abordé le problème du foncier en
outre-mer les enjeux fonciers dans nos
pays du tournèrent c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose de très très important et
nous avons donc fait un travail avec
Philippe Schmitt mais également avec de
l'ensemble des intercommunalités avec ma
collègue à côté donc Liliane qui a été
également
aussi notamment pour la Guadeloupe sur
la problématique également du foncier
aura peut-être l'occasion tout à l'heure
d'intervenir je présume sur le problème
du foncier agricole parce que tu as eu
un exemple très concret à nous dire
également la difficulté qui que nous
rencontrons c'est vrai que ce document
monsieur le Président c'est un document
sur l'enjeu foncier et tout à l'heure
donc
quand je passerai la parole également à
Philippe Schmitt sur le fait quand on a
donc
auditionné en quelque sorte les on a
positionné ce qu'on appelle les dromes
c'est à dire la Mayotte je vais Mayotte
la Réunion
ensuite la Guyane la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique et ce qui ressort surtout
donc dans ce document c'est
effectivement nos 44 propositions et il
y a notamment également le problème
quand on aborde le foncier agricole il y
a le commission c'est des pénards qu'on
aura l'occasion également d'aborder tout
à l'heure je tiens tout d'abord qu'à
vous remercier donc de boîte à vitesse
la participer à cette audition et
féliciter bien sûr la délégation
sénatoriale d'avoir engagé ce travail
sur le foncier agricole comme vous le
savez interco outre-mer
qui est donc
une association qui a été créée en 2001
je suis fait partie du monde fondateur
de cette association
à l'époque ça plaît donc la Conférence
des Présidents et des vice-présidents
des intercaut outre-mer et de rapidement
on s'est dit bon il faut quand même
l'élargir et on a donc un palais appelé
ça tout bonnement interco outre-mer ça
me rajeunit pas depuis 2001
effectivement mais bon je suis encore là
c'est pour moi et donc un dossier très
très important notamment la défense des
intérêts de nos pays d'outre-mer à
travers le foncier donc nous avons
élaboré donc ce plan de mobilisation à
faire afin d'aboutir à ce recueil de
propositions d'observation et d'alerte
sur le plan la problématique foncière
ce recueil et le fruit d'un travail
constaté des intercommunalités
d'outre-mer et de leur communes je dis
bien parce que ça a été quand même
extrêmement important les réunions que
nous avons réalisées dans les cinq pays
de
la préoccupation politique que ce site
les enjeux fonciers pour la très grande
majorité d'entre eux ces enjeux
présentent de nombreuses similitudes ont
des territoires mais avec des niveaux
d'acuité constatés constatées dans la
déclination déclinaison opérationnelle
et je nous disons donc ce sera surtout
également de tenir compte et de faire en
sorte que on y gagnera tous à faire en
sorte que ce soit territoire par
territoire parce que c'est aussi il y a
aussi un tronc commun mais il y a aussi
des spécificités Mayotte c'est pas la
Guyane même s'ils ont le même problème
pas dire en ce qui concerne
l'immigration mais un peu d'intérêts
plus petit c'est ce qu'on a eu
l'occasion de le dire
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique et énergétique il y a deux
jours
ayons à l'esprit que tous les élus de
France le foncier et la matière première
de l'aménagement et du développement de
territoires et les transformations
environnementales et climatiques en font
une matière particulièrement sensible
plus encore à l'heure du Zéro
artificialisation net ce qu'on appelle
le fameux âne qui est compliqué pour
nous dans les pays d'outre-mer mais pour
les lutromer c'est aussi davantage que
dans l'Hexagone un sujet de société
de culture
d'organisation des acteurs publics
d'outils de gouvernance raison pour
laquelle toutes nos réflexions ont eu
profil conducteur la dimension
culturelle et historique de la terre
le rôle et la place de l'État dans le
pilotage foncier le désordre foncier que
vous avez fait allusion à l'instant
monsieur le Président propriété
notamment mais aussi de l'indivision
les titresment
la connaissance et la formation enfin la
planification et la ménagement
opérationnelle
le déroulé de la matinée ne me permet
pas de vous livrer la quarantaine de
propositions qui découlent du travail de
terrain que nous avons mené toutefois je
souhaite partager avec vous quelques
points de réflexion provenant de nos
travaux et qui me semble indispensable
lorsqu'on aborde le foncier sous l'angle
agricole si l'expertise faite par notre
association n'est pas dédié
spécifiquement aux fonctions agricoles
nous avons ouvert nos réflexions aux
enjeux agricoles et avons pu échanger
avec des différents acteurs tels que la
SAFER les dafes etc de nos cinq
territoires il faut reconnaître que
lorsque l'on évoque le sujet du foncier
avec les acteurs politiques et
administratifs la problématique agricole
n'est pas la première mentionnée ce qui
est peut-être également dommageable et
c'est comme c'est le cas il faut le dire
entre nous il faut pas parce qu'on a dit
avoir le nom de bois parce que c'est
c'est ce qui se passe quand on
il y a donc une démarche à mener de
conscientisation du sujet agricole qui
doit venir des collectivités elles-mêmes
certaines collectivités ont d'ores et
déjà amorcé ce processus je parlais donc
de Liliane piquant à mes côtés je pense
notamment à celle de cap excellence en
Guadeloupe laquelle s'attache à mener
des actions concrètes se sont
territoires et tout à l'heure donc je
pense que tu vas intervenir Guillian et
au-delà des constats il faut réellement
s'interroger sur le modèle agricole que
les autorités et collectivités
souhaitent mettre en place sur leur
territoire chacun de leur territoire
encore une fois en différenciant les
territoires
hormis le fait que le sujet du
foncervicole ne soit pas toujours bien
appréhender en effet les collectivités
sont mal connaître le sujet du fonction
agricole il serait judicieux de
développer des process de collaboration
partenariats entre les entités publiques
et privés du monde agricole et les
collectivités l'idée étant de
privilégier la collaboration et non la
norme parce que souvent ce qu'on appelle
nous dans ce document ce qu'on appelle
travailler dans la co-construction il
s'agit là de quelques remarques en
préambule je tout à l'heure donc je vais
donc céder vous avez fait effectivement
toute une série de questionnaires 10
questions alors je monopoliser la parole
je laisserai la parole de suite la
parole à Caroline punisse et felich
Schmitz qui ont mené le travail de
terrain d'animation je dis bien
d'animation de ce recueil financier et
ensuite les liens si tu souhaites
juste une PC une précision ce président
pour tous ceux qui vous accompagnent
vous avez effectivement adressé une
trame de questions on espère avoir une
réponse écrite
on peut traverser ce questionnaire ce
matin de manière tout à fait libre en
fonction de ce que vous souhaitez déjà
partager à ce stade avec
aucun problème l'exercice est assez
libre c'est simplement un guide pour
vous permettre de nous passer des
messages notamment les messages clés que
vous avez commencé à nous passer dans
votre introduction je vous remercie bien
merci peut-être Liliane sur comme
sollicité dans le dans mon propos
introductif vas-y
je sais pas si
voilà
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs et bien merci
vraiment de nous accueillir pour parler
d'un sujet aussi prégnant que celui du
foncier en général et en fait
personnellement j'attache une importance
toute particulière aux fonciers
agricoles puisque nous sommes dans dans
une île où on parle beaucoup d'autonomie
alimentaire et si on ne dégage pas
suffisamment se foncier alimentaire et
qu'on voit énormément de friches de
disponibilité qui pourrait se dégager
et en tout cas aujourd'hui que
des fonds
liés à l'histoire à notre histoire à
l'esclavage mais
je le dis et je le redis souvent nous
devons nous appuyer sur le passé pour
avancer parce que c'est un pays la
Guadeloupe c'est plus de 27% de chômage
donc il y a là une vraie préoccupation
si on n'a pas si on ne dégage pas un
foncier sain en tenant compte de la
problématique de la chlordécone et bien
on y arrivera pas donc il faut une
action forte et
j'avoue que personnellement en
Guadeloupe et chacun d'entre nous sans
aucun doute ont beaucoup apprécié ce
rapport fourni par le cabinet
urbain demain
et en même temps mandaté par le
président de capexcellence c'est avec
Caroline Kunis également qui a
accompagné
cette question là
c'est une base de travail extrêmement
importante parce que je ne pense pas en
tout cas ce que je sache qu'on les fait
avant donc interco outre-mer a vraiment
pris cette question à bras le corps pour
que nous ayons des solutions
apportées en co-construction comme l'a
dit le président et j'espère vraiment
que nous aurons des solutions pratiques
moi mon métier de chef d'entreprise
m'emmène à dire qu'il faut être
pragmatique qu'il faudrait que les que
les formalités administratives en soi
simplifiées ça c'est extrêmement
important et je dirais même que c'est la
base parce qu'on manque des dossiers il
y a de vraies demandes il y a des jeunes
qui sont en attente j'ai pris
l'initiative à un certain moment de me
rendre au lycée agricole en disant
jeunes il faut y aller formez-vous
d'abord on va créer le vrai filière
agricoles parce qu'on parle d'autonomie
alimentaire qui ne dépend pas uniquement
de la production agricole mais la de la
d'abord de la diversification à partir
de la canne banane que nous connaissons
et surtout de la transformation pour
créer de la valeur ajoutée donc de la
richesse et des emplois ça c'est cette
casquette de chef d'entreprise qui
m'emmène à insister là-dessus parce que
ce dossier là est une référence très
forte maintenant il faut arriver à
trouver à travers la co-construction
entre les différents partenaires qui ont
été vus et surtout ce qui est à retenir
c'est que ce cette présentation de la
plateforme foncière a été présentée aux
élus mais aussi aux techniciens qui
doivent aller plus sur le terrain et aux
politiques qui doivent s'engager dans
cette démarche de manière à concrétiser
et à pas arriver à l'autonomie
alimentaire mais au moins attendre a
puisque nous avons 80% des produits qui
viennent de l'hexagone et qui de
l'examen de l'Hexagone ou d'ailleurs
donc notre démarche avec vous c'est de
trouver les voies et les moyens pour
pouvoir avancer et en faire de vrais
métiers et puis aussi il y a l'histoire
mais il y a aussi les blocages les
questions d'indivision de transmission
qui ne se font pas et les questions de
division et même je dirais qui est qui
deviennent agressive je prends l'exemple
concret j'en ai parlé hier
je connais quelqu'un qui achète un
certain nombre d'hectares de fonciers en
bonne et due forme ça veut dire le
notaire les fonds la banque etc à
travers un prêt bancaire
37 hectares qui fait un projet
majestueux pour la production la
transformation des plantes aromatiques
et médicinales bio qui obtient un prix à
l'international
donc qui est primé
certifié bio européen et local et bien
c'est bloqué il y a un conflit parce que
le poids de l'histoire fait que les
occupants disent que c'était à nos
ancêtres et ça je dis que c'est pas
normal même quand on leur propose une
petite partie gratuitement pour qu'ils
attache les bœufs et qu'on leur propose
d'embaucher leurs enfants de les former
dans le cadre de l'insertion puis de
donner un emploi stable en durant
indéterminée et bien il y a un certain
nombre de blocages aujourd'hui qu'il
faut lever et à ce jour 10 ans plus tard
personne n'a fait aussi bien que ce qui
avait commencé à être fait et dont on a
beaucoup parlé par des prix etc et par
l'efficacité de ces produits biologiques
donc ce n'est qu'un exemple à parmi
d'autres mais il en existe beaucoup ça
n'est pas en restant dans cette
situation qu'on arrivera à faire émerger
des nouveaux métiers à innover et avoir
des produits de qualité à travers la
production agricole pour le moment je
m'arrêterai là mais il y a un vrai
problème et je pense qu'on a pas
beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de temps pour réagir je vous
remercie bien
on va engager le sujet sur la cdp9
non c'était simplement pour pour
souligner que la problématique du
foncier agricole tel que tel que vous la
prenez pour vos travaux on l'a bien dit
le président l'a dit elle était pas au
cœur de notre sujet nous on l'a toujours
abordé le sujet comme du foncier comme
une matière
mais sans pré sans préjugés
de son usage d'accord on parlait et
c'est vrai le président l'ADIL la
dimension agricole des foncier elle
vient pas spontanément donc ça qu'on se
garde et moi je pense il est très
important qu'on maintienne l'idée qu'on
a un enjeu un peu culturel d'éveil de
construction des stratégies etc sur le
foncier agricole la visibilité de
l'action publique sur foncier agricole
elle est pas évidente
moi je voudrais juste si vous voulez
bien on pourrait pointer deux trois
éléments majeurs que vous avez
d'ailleurs souligné dans votre
questionnaire
là je vais laisser Caroline parler un
petit peu de la cdp9 à ce que je pense
que ça fait partie des sujets un petit
peu importants mais
je voudrais revenir en m'appuyant sur la
formulation de la question 6 voilà en
disant faciliter la construction
d'habitat pour les exploitants agricoles
dans les autres mers et moi spontanément
c'est une réflexion et là vous nous
invitez à réfléchir sur la base du
travail et c'est pas le fruit de d'un
travail déjà mené coco qu'on vous livre
mais la question qui me vient c'est
c'est quoi un exploitant agricole
je dis ça parce que de mon point de vue
il est très très important qu'on sache
exactement ce qu'est un exploitant
agricole en outre-mer parce que vous
saviez quand vous reprenez uniquement
les définitions au sens Insee de ce
qu'est un exploitant agricole on voit
que
ils vont il faut il faut
il faut excusez-moi il faut être
répondre à des
on a à la fois faut remplir la condition
en terme de surface et on dit ah mais la
S a eu un hectare
un hectare
il faut répondre à des conditions enfin
en termes de production ou de nombre
d'animaux mais maintenant il faut qu'on
se mette par exemple aux Antilles par
exemple en Guadeloupe voilà
un hectare avec quelques boeufs fait de
moine un exploitant agricole voilà et
même si je suis dans ce qu'on peut
appeler l'agriculture
d'autosuffisance familiale vous voyez et
donc au sens au sens
de la MSA ou au sens de qu'est-ce qu'on
va qualifier comme exploitant agricole
je dis ça parce que c'est extrêmement
important vous savez que là il y a une
tension très forte entre la logique
agricole et la logique de l'urbanisation
et puis vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président ça grignote et ça grignote ça
grignote
il faudra manier
avec beaucoup de prudence nous
semble-t-il l'idée qu'on puisse
encourager la construction agricole sur
les terrains au regard de la structure
des exploitations agricoles qui sont
d'un territoire à l'autre nous
semble-t-il quand même très variable
parce que on peut pas par exemple si on
compare la manière dont des structuré la
l'activité agricole en Martinique en
Guadeloupe on peut pas les mettre dans
le même panier on va avoir d'un côté des
exploitants agricoles qui ont 2000
hectares de bananes avec des filières
qui sont très structurées qui peuvent
nous aider à bien comprendre ce qu'est
l'activité agricole et de l'autre côté
on peut avoir une foultitude de de
gens qui peuvent être reconnus avec
hulteur MSA
sans pour autant être dans des logiques
de filières de développement et mais
plus proche des logiques de consommation
je sais pas si vous partagez ce regard
là tout ça pour dire que si on fait
notamment à travers la loi ou travers
des systèmes d'encouragement
en se disant je vais aider le foncier
agricole parce que je vais permettre
l'installation des jeunes exploitants et
c'est un point vous certainement vous
allez auditionner les affaires et ben
les je me souviens très très bien par
exemple à cette Guadeloupe dire le
problème c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à
loger et à installer nos exploitants
mais moi je dis tout simplement
attention
à la fausse bonne idée et au risque de
dérapage très importants qu'il y a sur
cette idée d'encourager la création
parce que tout le monde si j'ai envie de
dire là c'est sous le contrôle des élus
mais beaucoup beaucoup de propriétaires
de terrain vont dire c'est un terrain
que je veux exploiter je suis chez moi
il faut que je puisse y loger voilà et
ça risque d'être un argument utilisé
pour dire j'ai un droit à construire etc
donc on est sur un point de mon produit
qu'il faut vraiment expertiser avec
beaucoup beaucoup de précisions dans la
définition de ce qu'est un exploitant
agricole
je sais pas si cet observation peut tu
veux dire un mot sur la CD P9 et puis
après moi je on peut rebondir après sur
deux trois idées
en fait les
oui c'est bon comme ça effectivement si
je me rapproche pas du micro oui
concernant la CD P9 c'est vrai que alors
vous le savez c'est un avis conforme
dans les outre-mer assez mal souvent mal
vécues par par les élus qui a un avis
qui a tendance à figer à fermer les
positions donc les élus
l'interco outre-mer ne demande pas à vie
conforme ou à vie simple mais une nuance
en fait dans leur dans leur proposition
à ce que les collectivités locales et
régions et départements puissent choisir
quel type d'avis il pourrait il pourrait
avoir donc avec le choix entre nuancer
la vie ou l'accorder sous sous réserve
revenir à un avis simple avec un recours
possible ou conserver la vie conforme si
c'est le souhait de la collectivité
institué ou non le principe d'une
prédépin NAF qui est déjà pratiqué dans
certains territoires et qui est vécu
comme quelque chose qui encourage le
dialogue et donc dépasse un peu le
statut de tribunal vécu un peu de la CD
pénaves un prêt concernant le
fonctionnement et la composition de la
commission il y a des effectivement des
des
propositions aussi des élus
d'intercoutre-mer donc qui consiste à
repenser la composition de la cdpaf par
exemple en y faisant ses sièges des
représentants des EPCI dont les
stratégies en matière d'aménagement et
développement sont au premier rang des
compétences et des responsabilités donc
on pourrait aussi élargir les missions
de la cdp9 en unifiant cette commission
avec d'autres instances existantes
telles que la CDNPS la CDK et en faire
une conférence territoriale de
l'aménagement plus donc ça c'est une
proposition aussi des élus
organiser aussi des commissions
thématiques au choix des élus locaux
pour encourager leur mobilisation et
leur participation on pourrait aussi
renforcer la reconnaissance de cette
commission auprès de l'ensemble des
acteurs par exemple en Guyane la cdp9
souffre d'un manque évident de notoriété
c'est ce qui a été souligné par les élus
de de Guyane et voilà donc ça c'était
pour la CD9 on nuance les élus demande à
vraiment nuancer la vie en fonction des
territoires je pense que pas d'avis
forcément conforme ni simple mais nuancé
en fonction au choix des collectivités
aujourd'hui concernant les pays
d'outre-mer il y a dans ce cas c'est
dans la Constitution ça a été donc c'est
vraiment voir comment qu'on peut sortir
ce blocage actuel c'est donc laisser
quand même la possibilité donc d'être un
peu plus souple or aujourd'hui là c'est
des pédophes quand il a pris une
décision c'est il y a pas de recours
possible mais surtout également c'est
que c'était aujourd'hui dans la dans la
Constitution concernant les pays
d'outre-mer c'est-à-dire conforme donc
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter bien sûr
je me disais les pommes c'est Guillaume
j'avais eu l'occasion de discuter avec
le président de la République également
donc quand il était venu à la Réunion
ils sont conscients que bon ben il y a
un souci vraiment mais c'est vrai que
j'ai eu l'occasion également de discuter
avec Monsieur le conducteur ministre des
Outre-mer ils sont tous conscients mais
le problème c'est que ce que nous
concerne les pays d'outre-mer et bien on
est dans la Constitution il faut le
sortir là-dedans mais ça c'est pas
évident voilà je tenais à dire ça aussi
peut-être bon vous êtes sûrement plus
informés que moi c'est clair voilà
une toute petite remarque peut-être en
complément de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure
si on considère si vous partagiez l'idée
qu'il puisse y avoir des risques de
dérive avec l'idée de l'encouragement à
pouvoir construire pour s'installer si
vous partagez cette cette analyse avec
donc des risques de dérive à un
encouragement à la construction pour des
très petites exploitations etc je pense
qu'il faudrait réfléchir à l'idée de
grever le foncier agricole de ce qu'on
appelle les obligations réelles
environnementales c'est-à-dire avoir une
sorte de
d'engagement lié
à la propriété même donc ce sont des
servitudes qui sont inscrites dans les
titres de propriété les obligations
réelles environnementales de telle sorte
qu'ils puissent être assurés la vocation
agricole sur le très long terme du
terrain c'est-à-dire qu'en substance si
on veut travailler sur le conseil
agricole soit on travaille à travers les
documents d'urbanisme qui fixent les
destinations des sols etc soit on peut
travailler à l'échelle du terrain
lui-même et où à ce titre là inscrire
une vocation agricole à travers ses
obligations réelles environnementales
qui
qui assure
que ça puisse être vraiment inscrit sur
le long terme je sais pas si
c'est une piste
pour aller dans le même sens que
Philippe Schmidt par exemple quand un
agriculteur s'installe s'il veut sur
place faire de la transformation et que
c'est un foncier entre guillemets
protégé selon la loi Ramsa qui dit que
seuls peuvent construire un bâtiment un
bâtiment à condition que la la fonction
d'agriculture soit à condition que le
bâtiment soit en lien avec
l'agriculteur l'agriculture pardon et là
il y a un réel blocage en Guadeloupe je
sais pas si dans les autres
le problème est aussi important mais
c'est un foncier encore une fois
toujours la même histoire qui a été
bloquée au motif que on est dans le
cadre de la loi hamsa et bien je trouve
pas ça très malin parce que si on
transforme sur place on fait des
mutualise
les différentes étapes et on peut il est
normal qu'on passe de la production à la
semi transformation tout au moins sur le
même lieu de production et là il y a un
problème je crois qu'on applique la loi
stricto-sensuit on tient pas compte de
la loi et de l'esprit de la loi et ça je
trouve que c'est pas normal il y a un
réel problème à ce niveau-là
je vais laisser la parole au rapporteur
ce qui va permettre un échange on va
continuer les échanges et puis vous
apporter les éléments d'information
complémentaires il y a aucun sujet je
vais peut-être commencer par par Vivette
ou répartissez la parole mes chers
rapporteurs merci monsieur le Président
merci d'être de galanterie
[Musique]
[Rires]
exactement exactement
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
merci beaucoup de vos éclairages qui
sont
qui vont vraiment apporter de l'eau de
l'eau à notre moulin votre rapport est
excellent je me souviens de l'audition
que vous m'aviez faite
sur le sujet sur le sujet à Mayotte et
vraiment c'est
réjouissant de travailler dans dans des
conditions où nous avons déjà de la
matière et où nous cherchons à améliorer
améliorer les choses
je crois que c'est vous madame Pikine
Salomé qui avait dit tout à l'heure
les indivisions sont là ils ne se font
pas de
se résolve pas vous le savez vous savez
les travaux que nous avons menés ici à
la Délégation aux outre-mer du Sénat
à l'occasion desquelles nous sommes
attaqués à ces problèmes d'indivision
plusieurs solutions ont été émises
la loi litchimie elle-même a été
inspirée par
par nos travaux
les solutions juridiques sont là pour
partie
et parmi les solutions
à l'époque j'avais proposé à notre
délégation de mettre en place un maillot
d'une cuve une commission de l'urgence
foncière
[Musique]
et
la réflexion sur cette cuve moi je
m'étais inspiré de ce qui s'était fait à
Mayotte juste avant la
départementalisation où il était
question de réformer l'État civil avant
d'entrer dans la départementalisation
les autres DOM
exister depuis 1946 donc moi je ne
pensais pas que une telle
invention
pouvait être valable aussi pour les
autres domaines aujourd'hui
la cuve a commencé son travail et
au fur et à mesure de l'avancée de ces
travaux nous nous rendons compte que il
y a des ajustements à faire il y a de
nouveaux textes à voter et notamment
nous avons fait passer un amendement
dans la loi 3DS et ma première question
va porter là-dessus est-ce que vous
pensez que dans les autres territoires
une telle institution
serait nécessaire pour s'occuper
particulièrement de la problématique de
l'indivision nous avions préconisé aussi
la mise en place des tribunal fonciers
en Polynésie française c'est désormais
le cas et les choses sont en train
d'avancer et donc est-ce que dans les
autres territoires
une instance du style cuve commission
d'urgence foncière ou tribunal fonciers
voilà donc vous me répondez que oui
c'est c'est chose faites ma deuxième ma
seconde question
est relative à la transmission
nous avons dans le cadre de nos
auditions constater qu'il y avait un
sacré problème de transmission
des exploitations agricoles dû à
plusieurs facteurs notamment
la petite s des des pensions agricoles
qui mis bout à bout avec
la non-valorisation
des fonds agricoles fait que
ces deux circonstances font que et bien
les exploitants qui sont là Russie
a laissé leur exploitation
ça contrib UE à
aux indivisions puisque
il y a même des pratiques qui consistent
à quand même transmettre mais sans que
ça soit sans que ça soit légal et moi
j'étais très intéressé par votre
proposition numéro 11
[Musique]
donc qui vient qui vient répondre à la
problématique de l'indivision mais mais
il y a aussi un texte de 2000 de 2006
une loi du 5 janvier 2006 qui qui
tend à donner
au fond agricole la même valeur à peu
près que le fond de commerce à votre
connaissance est-ce que ce texte
s'applique à notre maire et est-ce qu'il
n'y aurait pas besoin de rendre un tel
texte applicable à notre mère pour
valoriser ses fonds agricoles et
contribuer à faciliter leur transmission
aux générations plus jeunes voilà les
les deux principales questions que
j'avais à vous poser
moi je veux peut-être rebondir justement
sur cette transmission on a cru
comprendre que quand même certains
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça aussi quand ils
arrivent à la retraite ne veulent pas
transmettre parce qu'ils ne sont pas
vraiment
propriétaires c'est-à-dire ils
exploitent depuis de nombreuses années
peut-être depuis la fin de l'esclavage
on leur a donné ces terres mais il n'y a
jamais eu de cadastre et de titres
propriétés les choses n'ont pas été
faites correctement donc je pense que ça
ça pose c'est le premier des problèmes
comment pourrait-on résoudre ce problème
pas d'être très compliqué ça c'est
compliqué mais enfin oui parce que
depuis le temps il a dû avoir des décès
des voilà qui est et donc les ancêtres
ont laissé à leurs enfants
ils restaient sur le terrain pour
surtout qu'on ne lui reprenne pas donc
je pense que ça c'est vraiment un point
qui serait à régler sincèrement parce
qu'on a même cru comprendre que certains
seraient prêts à céder leur terre un
loquant de mettre un location mais
qu'une fois que la personne est dessus
au bout de trois mois ne paye plus de
loyer et dit ben c'est bon je suis chez
moi c'est moi qui exploite c'est moi ça
me paraît un peu impensable mais voilà
ça c'est une question qui quand même je
crois est vraiment primordial pour la
transmission et moi j'aurais souhaité
comme au deuxième question que vous me
m'évoquiez la question de l'irrigation
parce que ça c'est un gros problème
aussi alors on nous dit qu'il y a des
projets
pharaoniques je ne sais pas est-ce que
vous pensez que ce problème devrait être
pris au niveau intercommunal
et quels sont les enjeux bien évidemment
financiers et foncier dans les outre-mer
pour ce problème d'irrigation je vous
remercie
si vous permettez je ne sais pas si
c'est une question qui doit être prise
en compte par les communautés
d'agglomération en tout cas le problème
de la sécheresse c'est un vrai problème
et les aléas climatiques à travers
notamment les cyclones et tout ça et
c'est vrai que l'agriculteur il gagne
pas bien sa vie alors comment faire pour
les questions d'irrigation peut-être des
bassins de rétention il y a sûrement des
alternatives qu'on pourrait mettre en
place mais c'était un réel problème
effectivement parce que lors de quand il
y a une grande sécheresse les meloniers
les tous ceux qui cultivent des fruits
des légumes etc on de réelles
difficultés et perdre leurs production
ça existe partout mais dans dans nos
îles c'est un peu plus particulier
donc bassin de rétention et autres il
faut y réfléchir sérieusement et
voilà
sur ce sujet de l'irrigation nous vous
verrez dans le petit retour qu'on va
vous faire mais
un point sur lequel on n'a pas
d'expertise particulière et qui n'a pas
été particulièrement abordé dans nos
travaux cependant si on réfléchit
l'échelle intercommunale est-elle la
bonne pour travailler ça
de fait l'eau
ça dépasse les limites communales c'est
clair mais on sait très bien que toutes
ces sujets de l'eau ben c'est les
géographie physique puisque les
géographies administratives qui mais il
n'empêche que il nous semble
que la la réflexion doit être menée au
regard des compétences des collectivités
qu'est-ce que c'est l'irrigation ont
soit on peut la rattacher à une
compétence eau en disant donc qui est
compétence haut alors donc il y a
beaucoup d'agglomérations mais c'est là
et vous vous a remis vous verrez dans
notre retour un rappel que une grosse
étude à laquelle l'association
intercoutre-mer avec participé en lien
avec interco de France une grosse étude
sur ce que sont les communautés
d'outre-mer dans leur compétences dans
leur profil financier dans machin etc
c'est un peu un gros pavé mais ça mérite
vraiment qu'on s'y intéresse qui est
compétent en quoi d'accord donc ici je
pense à irrigation à nos yeux ça peut
croiser une compétence eau une
compétence environnementale et une
compétence économique si je considère
que la dimension agricole et nous
semble-t-il une fois qu'elle le soit a
aussi un poids économique et donc est
dans une compétence économique et je
pense qu'il faudrait ce travail que nous
n'avons pas fait mais regardez
véritablement avant de se prononcer
parce que j'entends la prudence de Elvis
résidente à disant attention l'interco
l'interco en outre-mer c'est
indispensable il y a des voies de de des
initiatives voilà on sait que ça sert
mais il faut aussi être lucide sur les
difficultés que l'on ne peut avoir dans
la relation commune interco sur le
manières de fait faire intercommunalité
c'est et donc qu'une proposition
sénatoriale que de confier des
responsabilités nouvelles sur des sujets
qui m'avaient tous sont des sujets à
autant haute tension on le voit dans
l'Hexagone on voit très bien que parler
d'irrigations c'est ça va être de plus
en plus compliqué sur le champ politique
et certainement est-ce que c'est que y
compris
aux Antilles parler haut ça va devenir
de plus en plus quoi surtout oui
ensemble c'est bien en Guadeloupe c'est
compliqué par les hauts déjà
alimentation pot de ça mais où
irrigation voilà donc tout ça pour dire
quoi que c'est un enjeu politique qui
devient très fort si vous avez et moi je
pense que c'est assez sain de réfléchir
à comment va organiser cette
responsabilité je pense qu'il faut bien
voir avant de décréter que c'est une
automatiquement intercommunale c'est
elle était votre idée voilà qu'on arrive
bien à voir comment une compétence
irrigation ça se place dans les autres
compétences et dans les stratégies donc
qui est capable de faire quoi comment
pour placer ce sujet
je voudrais également compléter donc le
propos donc de Philippe je me c'est le
problème
des compétences concernant l'irrigation
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les intercos
ont eu la compétence depuis le 1er
janvier 2020 de l'eau et
d'assainissement
mais l'irrigation c'est toujours une
compétence pour ce qui concerne la
réunion du département qui a la
compétence agricole
et il y a eu je crois que c'est Madame
tout à l'heure elle va sénatrice qui a
dit qu'il y a eu des projets
pharaoniques c'est vrai notamment à la
Réunion un projet de basculement de
l'eau de l'ouest de l'AS vers l'Ouest
qui a coûté plus du milliard qui était
financé par l'Europe et tout
très très fortement et mais le problème
aujourd'hui c'est le coût de
l'irrigation
si on met le coût réel de liguration
aucun perguteur peut pour irriguer ce
terrain donc c'est très subventionné
c'est à dire que l'agriculteur
aujourd'hui il paye le chapi ou le mètre
cube
de powerguer son terrain d'ailleurs il
trouve que c'est déjà trop cher mais il
paye pas au prix de revient
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle donc une
aide donc c'est et on sait également que
par exemple à la Réunion
c'est vrai que c'est la région qui a
donc qui est le pilote économique des
régions les différents pays et c'est
vrai également que nous travaillons
normalement donc en concert avec
l'interco et la région et la région
en janvier 2028
va donc
demander de transférer de compétences de
l'agriculture agricole du département à
la région ça a été acté par les deux
présidents la Présidente de la Région et
le président du département et donc mais
ça coûte il faut savoir que l'irrigation
coûte très très cher et donc maintenant
je sais qu'il y a des communes également
ou des groupements de communes notamment
des communes plutôt la commune du Tampon
voilà cité a également mis en place
en même temps qu'ils ont un réseau donc
d'eau potable ils ont mis en place parce
qu'on appelle un réseau d'irrigation et
de réseaux différents
et là aussi
c'est très subventionné
et c'est le réseau d'irrigation et
réaliser après donc des retenues
colinaires énormes dans les hautes de
tampon il y a plein de CAF et qui permet
ensuite donc d'avoir cette irrigation
gravitairement
et cette
investissement qui était énorme a été
aidé subventionné heureusement
d'ailleurs
après 80% par le FEDER par l'État par
l'Europe donc c'est pour dire que il y a
eu beaucoup beaucoup d'investissements
notamment européens dans la
problématique donc de l'irrigation à la
Réunion je prends l'exemple de la
réunion je connais un peu plus
d'ailleurs mais je voudrais également
répondre au sénateur donc
c'est sur
la comment valoriser le fond agricole
nous on pense qu'il faut le faire
quelqu'un qui a donc effectivement je
pense que ça pourrait répondre résoudre
maintenant est-ce que ça va résoudre on
sait pas mais il faudrait réfléchir à ça
quelqu'un qui a donc exploite un terrain
depuis je peux pas nombreuses années il
a il a donc
il a un fond en quelque sorte même si tu
appartient pas le terrain voir comment
c'est un peu comme un petit peu un fond
de commerce et ce serait bien
effectivement qu'on puisse réfléchir à
ça moi je suis je pense que d'ailleurs
on l'a également abordé dans notre
document donc c'est vrai que c'est
quand même à savoir faire connard donc
même si c'est un peu peut-être
rudimentaire what mais il y a quand même
c'est pour la personne c'est ça on gagne
pas en quelque sorte on peut il faut pas
non plus lui dire bah non circuler il y
a rien à voir quoi donc il faut des voir
effectivement si on a pas possibilité
aussi de mettre en place comment
valoriser ce fond agricole qui pourrait
donc en gros c'est le même système que
voilà
peut-être
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
de Monsieur rapporteur
au fil de nos échanges je pense que la
question de
de la compétence même parler
d'irrigation mais de fait les
compétences s'imposent s'imposeraient
même à certains compétences c'est un
collectivité et je trouve que justement
l'enjeu du foncier agricole d'un pays
d'outre-mer est un peu à la croisée de
d'autres défis et enjeux qui concerne
les pays d'outre-mer on parlait tout à
l'heure d'autonomie alimentaire j'ai
envie de parler d'autonomie énergétique
il y a la le défi de la croissance
démographique avec des conséquences
et sans les opposés
peut-être trouver les voies et moyens de
la complémentarité
peut-être que les problèmes des uns peut
être la solution des autres
effectivement on parle du cadastre
solaire on parle de ce mix énergétique
de développement énergies renouvelable
mais le déploiement ne serait-ce que des
panneaux photovoltaïques
demandent un foncier très important et
c'est souvent sur les terres agricoles
que les projets sont ciblés et il y a un
choix très compliqué à faire
qui va faire ce choix est-ce que c'est
l'État qui doit dire que sur ce terrain
agricole je favorise et je priorise mon
enjeu autonomie alimentaire au détriment
de l'autonomie énergétique au vice versa
ou l'agriculteur sur un terrain avec un
fort taux de rendement
et une perspective de revenus
de se dire je vais privilégier les
panneaux photovoltaïques au détriment de
d'autres productions
et je reviens sur les compétences et je
rejoins ce que disait Lilian tout à
l'heure sur comment encourager des
nouveaux exploitants agricoles
déjà il y a la question la propriété
mais la transmission de tout ce qui a
été dit
mais aussi sur la possibilité de
transformer sur place
mais ne serait-ce que de votre
Transformer à côté de son équation
demande l'arrivée de réseau
alors si on parle de réseau électrique
c'est peut-être la compétence A2 ou du
siddelec avec des fonds publics pour
amener le réseau qui coûte très cher et
très éloigné sur l'eau
toute la question de
notre reste pour transformer le produit
avec là aussi peut-être un besoin
électrique et d'autres besoins et la
question des chemins des patients
agricoles de nos pays d'outre-mer ou là
aussi finalement on sait pas trop c'est
la compétence de qui on sait pas trop
qui va le faire c'est pas trop qui a la
propriété pour le faire et là du coup ça
n'encourageait pas et ben les nouveaux
exploitants ou d'autres à venir donc et
enfin le dernier défi qui est à la
croisée dans le jeu du français agricole
c'est la question de la protection de
nos populations
on le voit aujourd'hui sur des terrains
en friche
où on peut avoir une volonté de
développer une exploitation et toutes
les conséquences directes sur du
ruissellement sur la gestion des eaux
pluviales et les conséquences directes
sur les populations avec des pays
d'outre-mer qui sont avec une
géographie une cartographie qui est
scalée et les conséquences peuvent être
direct donc vraiment il y a toutes ces
enjeux et toutes ces questions de
priorité face à ce nombreux défis
dont la responsabilité à la décision
n'est pas claire
et demain
si on doit prendre un seul exemple
d'avoir une exploitation agricole avec
une transformation on a plusieurs
collectivités qui devront mettre de
l'argent pour gérer les réseaux la
gestion des eaux pluviales etc etc avec
des coûts beaucoup plus importants
qui sont aujourd'hui dans l'état actuel
très peu cofinancé les questions de la
gemapi dans nos pays d'outre-mer ont
très peu de cofinancement alors qu'il y
a une question de sécurité de nos
populations
juste pour dire qu'à cela on pourrait
aussi imaginer
un nouveau modèle opératoire agricole et
économique en ce sens que déjà nous
avons la chlordécone qui qui limite
notre champ d'action mais il y a des
méthodes pour produire en hauteur et
optimiser l'espace agricole et là aussi
c'est une réflexion je pense qu'il
faudrait mener à côté de tous les
paramètres que viennent d'exposer Gilles
je crois que c'est vrai j'ai le pays a
raison quand il parle des défis et en
particulier donc nos pays d'outre-mer
l'objectif c'est d'arriver donc à
l'autonomie énergétique et également
l'autonomie ou l'autosuffisance
alimentaire etc il faut pas qu'on le
pose on ne pense pas là par rapport à
l'autre il faut absolument que ce soit
complémentaire
je prends un exemple simple quand on a
intérêt agricole aujourd'hui où on fait
la canne à sucre est demain on dit on
tient on va prendre une partie on va
faire autre chose on fera par exemple de
la vanille qui est donc un produit qui
est très hautement avec beaucoup de
valeur ajoutée et tout et on peut faire
la valise la vanille sous serre et la
serre en question au lieu de la faire
démontable ou autre on peut faire une
serre pour faire le dessus de panneaux
solaires et donc en même temps donc on
fait du sur le on fait de l'énergie et
en même temps on fait également
l'agricole c'est ça qu'il faut aussi que
là aussi que les services de l'État
parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a des voire même il y a des
contradictions on a des services un
service de l'État qui est d'accord
et à nos services qui dit non et ça
bloque
quand je dis c'est la délal et là c'est
l'agriculture
et qui sont aujourd'hui en attente et
c'est pour un agriculteur faire donc de
la culture que ce soit vivrière ou autre
sous serre c'est vrai que
c'est un investissement beaucoup plus
important parce que fait de la canne à
sucre on sait bien comment ça se passe
on a pour 3-4 mois de travaux à faire
pour préparer le champ etc etc après on
laisse pousser c'est pas le cas par
exemple
c'est pas le cas également donc là aussi
la canne à sucre nécessite pas non plus
d'amener de
chemin d'exploitation directement sur le
champ d'amener directement de l'eau ou
pour
faire transformation ou autre donc et
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est un réel
défi qu'on a mais on doit faire en sorte
que qu'on soit pas il faut pas que ce
soit donc c'est pour ces possibilités là
soit donc des freins et des et de dire
c'est l'un ou l'autre donc c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre pour nous c'est l'un et
l'autre on peut pas faire autrement
c'est comme ça
on aura on pourra jamais prendre un CAP
de Paris emmené à la Réunion pour avoir
de l'électricité on fera chez nous
autant le faire de façon autonome autant
le faire de façon propre
faire avoir donc l'autonomie énergétique
non pas l'autonomie énergétique qu'on
apporte de fioul ou du charbon mais
qu'on puisse faire chez nous à travers
de la biomasse à travers du soleil à
travers l'éolien et tout c'est mais en
même temps quand on dit ça j'ai un
projet
sur c'est pas un problème c'est une
réalisation c'est ça de Suzanne c'est ma
commune
c'est un exemple qui est à mon avis
parlant
je suis bien depuis quelques années j'ai
donc un peu de bouteille et j'ai donc
fait en sorte que effectivement ma
commune soit une commune à énergie
positive à partir de l'énergie
renouvelables à partir du solaire du
biogaz et de l'éolien nous avons ces
trois
sur le territoire ces trois choses
d'énergie sur le territoire et bien nous
avons donc
tout dernièrement moderniser donc des
éoliennes qui dataient 2013
vous avez 37 éoliennes qui étaient
anciennes générations à deux pales on a
donc changé et on a mis 9 éoliennes à
trois pales et les 9 éoliennes qu'on a
mis ça prend moins de place au sol c'est
un peu plus haut de 30 40 m ça fait 130
mètres et ça et en même temps ça produit
4 fois plus d'énergie que les 37 9
produits 4 fois plus et on aura donc
aujourd'hui auparavant on était une
commune comme on est dans une commune de
25000 habitants et nous posons
l'électricité pour l'équivalent 35000
habitants avec les éoliennes qu'on va
mettre en place nous allons produire
l'énergie propre
pour l'équivalent de 45000 habitants
donc ça veut dire que et on est 25000
habitants donc on apporte c'est possible
et en même temps sur ce dossier par
exemple d'éolienne nous avons travaillé
en bonne intelligence cette fois-ci
c'est bien avec la DR et la direction
l'agriculture parce que c'est bien sûr
les éoliens c'était un aléatoire
et bien on a concilié l'agriculture
c'est possible on a pu faire de la canne
on a fait des cultures des cultures
vivrières et nous avons fait avec la DAF
un projet de bergerie parce que sous les
éoliennes nous allons également mettre
des fermes photovoltaïque à une certaine
hauteur et sous la forme photovoltaïque
nous allons donc également mettre des
produits à du foin et du point du modèle
pour les impôts et on va faire un
élevage de moutons
une centaine de têtes et il y aura
également c'est une première et donc on
pense que c'est des choses comme ça et
là on voit bien que c'est pas c'est pas
grave histoire on fait de l'énergie et
en dessous on fait de l'agriculture et
tout le monde y gagne le l'agriculture
l'agriculteur qui était du coin et bien
c'est lui qui fera la bergerie on lui
paye en plus parce que celui qui
investit dans dans l'éolienne la tout
intérêt qu'effectivement sont
ces
équipements soient également sauvegardés
il a tout intérêt et en même temps
quelques emplois de proximité non
délocalisables voilà des choses qu'on
pourrait réfléchir et d'ailleurs et ça
ce n'est pas incompatible avec le mot
agricole voilà un exemple parmi tant
d'autres
puisque le temps avance et qu'on va
devoir un moment donné libérer la salle
je propose de pouvoir continuer avec le
collègue victoire en l'occurrence et
Marie-Laure ensuite
le président ainsi que l'ensemble des
intervenants je vous remercie déjà pour
les réponses que vous avez apportées
monsieur le président lors de votre
intervention enluminaire vous avez
évoqué les ânes et vous avez dit que on
fait d'après ce que j'ai compris en tout
cas que c'était compliqué alors on croit
c'est compliqué ce que vous pouvez
vraiment
nous dire ce que vous en pensez alors je
voudrais également concernant les
indivisions qui sont réelles
problématique également que vous
puissiez également nous dire pas le rôle
des notaires dans les fringues je dirais
est-ce que les notaires ne sont pas
aussi des freins quand il y a les à
volonté de la part des familles qui
souhaitent justement sortir de
l'indivision et aussi au niveau des
cadastre pour ce qui me concerne la
Guadeloupe et bien très souvent
d'après les informations que j'ai pu
avoir et bien il y a du carence en
personnel donc les bureaux de cadastre
sont fermés
parce qu'il y a pas de personnes pour
recevoir les
usagers voilà merci beaucoup
merci président d'abord vous dire que je
suis heureuse de vous retrouver là
l'équipe
dynamique compétente dans une autre vie
Président je les ai je les ai beaucoup
côtoyés et je suis très heureuse en tout
cas de vous retrouver aujourd'hui alors
ce que je voulais dire c'est que j'ai lu
avec beaucoup d'attention
le rapport sur l'enjeu foncier très bien
vraiment excellent rapport par contre il
y a une proposition qui a retenu mon
attention c'est celle qui porte sur les
occupations illégales qui fleurissent en
Guyane et à Mayotte donc c'est la
proposition 19 vous avez suggéré la mise
en place de procédures d'alerte entre
tous les acteurs afin d'accélérer
l'efficacité en Guyane vous le savez les
installations illégales n'ont cessé de
prendre de l'ampleur sous la pression
migratoire et ma question est simple
savez-vous si c'est procédure d'alerte
ont été mises en place pour une réaction
plus rapide des forces de l'ordre parce
que les agriculteurs en souffrent merci
beaucoup
avant de passer la parole également ah
oui excusez-moi
on termine avec Georges passion puis
après vous pouvez répondre en bloc ça
sera plus simple
anticipé même si on vous a demandé de le
faire par écrit connaître votre
appréciation sur l'activité des affaires
dans les outre-mer comme vous le savez
la Guyane est Mayotte était les deux
seuls à ne pas avoir de sa faire bon la
Guyane a maintenant la sienne
et
assez balbutiements parce qu'il y a
quand même eu beaucoup de désordres
autour de cette affaire pendant près de
Nantes
maintenant il y a une nouvelle
présidente qui semble vouloir dynamiser
la SAFER est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle
peut avoir sa place compte tenu des
expériences chez vous dans une Guyane ou
95% du foncier appartient encore à
l'état
que ce foncier même si bon j'ai pu lire
dans les questions
la Guyane était le seul de roman à ne
pas connaître de récession en matière de
foncier agricole mais quand même nous
avons beaucoup de contraintes
écologiques entre guillemets ou se
foncier est quand même attribué de façon
par-cimonieuse par l'État mettant en
avant effectivement la forêt primaire
qu'il faut
conserver
et puis également sur les questions de
financement parce que je vois que
l'essentiel de la question portait sur
le financement qu'il faudrait revoir
en l'adaptant spécificité du marché du
foncier est-ce que je peux savoir
comment ça fonctionne un peu cher un peu
chez vous pendant les autres dromes les
affaires
je veux pas répondre à tout donc je vais
ensuite distribuer la parole comme si
vous permettez donc tout d'abord sur les
ânes pour quelle raison que c'est
difficile à mettre en œuvre sur les
autres BH je ferai peut-être une
parenthèse par rapport à Guyane c'est
vrai que c'est 90 mm2 mais quoi que 95%
des terrains doivent appartiennent pas
appartiennent donc à l'état je sais pas
c'est facile également d'appliquer sur
artificialisation mais je prends un cas
simple qui est Mayotte avec les
problématiques notamment des
occupations illégales et tout mais aussi
avec tout ce qu'il y a donc dans les
hauteurs de Mamoudzou et tout on voit
bien ou si on m'a mis compris dans les
hauteur de la petite sœur et tout et
bien je vois mal comment que demain on
fera des opérations de logement et
appliquer donc 0 artificialisation c'est
c'est
compliqué donc c'est
avec les effets qu'ils ont à relever
aujourd'hui Mayotte c'est 374 km2
c'est donc
pas extensible voire même aujourd'hui
avec le volcan il y a des grises qui
étaient d'effondrement de l'emploi qui
pose qui pose également par exemple au
niveau de Mayotte la problématique de
l'arrondissement du port est-ce qu'il
faut faire là ou ailleurs une question à
parler
donc ça veut dire que il y a quand même
des difficultés et c'est pour cette
raison je disais donc les ânes pareil
c'est aussi pareil au niveau de la
Réunion la réunion nous avons donc
860 000 habitants nous avons donc 2500
km² certes nous allons quand 800 km² qui
sont disponibles disponibles pour la
rupture disponible parce que on ne peut
pas construire donc c'est normal
d'ailleurs il faut protéger nos forêt
primaire notamment donc le parc national
il faut protéger il y a aussi on a
beaucoup de montagnes et puis on des
neiges puis on a fournaise et tout donc
je sais pas si vous avez les images
c'est pas évident
malheureusement d'ailleurs on pourra pas
non plus c'est quand même formidable ces
sites là donc il faut absolument les
sauvegarder donc il ne reste que 800
km/h à partir de là donc c'est vrai
c'est la raison de notre dossier on dit
ce serait dans le nécessaire on dit pas
qu'il faut bétonner partout attention
c'est pas non plus parce que je crois
que y compris à Mayotte c'est pas non
plus leur demande mais partout parce que
ça correspond pas non plus au type de
outils de de d'habitat qu'on voudrait
donc mais en même temps il faudrait
quand même que y ait et j'ai cru
comprendre également que y compris ici
en France hexagonale il y a des communes
qui disent ben non n'appliquez pas
bêtement sésame et donc
c'est encore si c'est valable dans cette
zone ici pourquoi pas chez nous donc
voilà un petit peu pour quelle raison
nous pensons que c'est pas possible de
l'appliquer aussi bête pour que ça voilà
alors
donc c'est vrai que j'ai pas la réponse
concernant les occupations illégales
donc par rapport à Mayotte et Guyane
alors est-ce que l'État répond des
façons efficaces ou autre je sais pas
moi-même j'étais à Mayotte juste avant
de venir ici pour
accueillir le président asiatique France
Monsieur Sébastien Martin que j'ai
accueilli également la réunion après et
on a eu l'occasion de visiter bien sûr
les fameux bidonville donc et également
les bidonvilles qui vont être rasés
l'occasion de visiter et tout et bien
c'est vrai que
c'est ces opérations qui sont menées le
président par exemple des départements
il dit c'est une bonne chose peut-être
mais c'est pas la solution
parce qu'ils disent aujourd'hui il y a
plus de 150 000
immigrés à Mayotte c'est à peu près ça
et j'ai appris cela j'ai appris aussi
j'étais étonné que c'est contrairement à
ce qu'on dit c'est pas que des Comoriens
c'est aussi les Africains c'est aussi
des Malgaches donc ça veut dire que
c'est un problème donc comment moi je
suis que ça merde
donc mais j'ai entendu moi ce discours
du Conseil du président du conseil
départemental de Mayotte qui est la
collectivité unique et qui disait que
donc il faudrait quand même réfléchir
alors celui-là ça faire et tout je
passerai tout à l'heure la parole donc
Philippe qui a donc eu l'occasion
également de faire la tournée des sacs
première sur ce document là mais avant
je suis la problématique des notaires
qui jouent au jeu ou pas ça tu veux bien
répondre
alors à ma connaissance en ce qui
concerne les notaires notamment en
Guadeloupe c'est extrêmement compliqué
dans le cadre des successions par
exemple je connais un deux trois une
dizaine de notaires et l'une en
particulier qui trente ans plus tard m'a
toujours pas libéré la succession quand
bien même c'est un partage judiciaire
puisque le tribunal donne 2 trop 3 ans
je crois pour régulariser et si ça ne
peut être fait doit faire un
procès-verbal de de comment ça se dit
déjà
oui voilà
donc je pense qu'il y a lieu
que l'État intervienne et
personnellement je m'apprête à écrire la
Chambre des notaires sur le plan
national pour tenter de débloquer une
situation que je connais parfaitement
mais c'est pas un cas particulier c'est
généralement et bien les notaires ils
prennent leur temps ils font pas le
boulot ils sont ils sont très négligents
ils prennent le temps et entre temps
s'il y a des liquidités
dans la succession et bien ça passe en
frais et puis voilà et ainsi de suite
donc je connais une famille qui en est
au cinquième notaire et c'est toujours
pas réglé au bout de 30 ans donc je
pense qu'il y a une vraie négligence
ou un certain moment il faut que l'État
ils mettent pardonnez-moi le terme ils
mettent le nez et vraiment je crois que
je là nous allons écrire à la Chambre
nationale des notaires donc il faut
remettre de l'ordre
on a besoin de votre appui pour ça
bienvenue on prend tout de suite
alors je vais prendre juste la parole si
vous permettez oui effectivement pardon
si si
merci
oui effectivement il y a un manque aussi
criant de notaire dans certains
territoires
par exemple à Mayotte c'est des notaires
de la Réunion qui qui se déplacent pour
pour régler les affaires à Mayotte il y
a aussi il y a aussi des sujets qui est
certes le rôle du notaire et met aussi
la présence des notaires et des autres
experts tels que les géomètres les
généalogistes et les élus demandent
justement un bilan de la présence de ces
de ces professions sur les cinq
territoires moi je voulais juste revenir
sur le cadastre qui effectivement est
une problématique sur tous les
territoires donc les élus demandent à ce
qui est une mise à jour et une
modernisation rigoureuse il est le socle
de l'aménagement donc c'est vrai que il
y a un véritable travail à faire au
niveau de la qualité des cadavres et ça
c'est c'est souligné sur les cinq sur
les cinq territoires
oui oui effectivement il y a la
situation foncière aussi importante à
un manque de connaissances des
patrimoine des collectivités publiques
comme privé et les élus demandent à ce
que il y a une photographie complète qui
soit qui soit élaborée des patrimoines
et notamment évidemment agricoles
il faut vraiment qu'on ait connaissance
de ce qui appartient aux collectivités
publiques comme privé niveau du foncier
dans les dix juste une toute petite
minute dans dans l'idée justement que
il y a besoin de davantage de dialogue
notamment déjà entre collectivités pour
bien savoir qui a quoi voilà parce qu'en
fait on croit savoir et on ne sait pas
et quand on certains maires nous disent
même moi la propriété de la commune je
sais voilà donc déjà dans un souci un
peu de responsabilité de visibilité il
faut pouvoir partager c'est pour ça
qu'on appellerait c'est de noter dans le
rapport un grand recensement général de
la propriété publique et privée dans les
territoires où est-ce qu'on est de quoi
on parle de quel foncier on parle ça
c'est
là ça fait le lien avec une autre idée
qui est présent dans le rapport mais qui
pour moi pour la dimension agricole me
paraît indispensable c'est qu'il y est
une
habitude de réunion et de conférence
annuelle de tous les acteurs sur le
foncier pour qu'on se parle parce que
dans les faits chacun est pareil dans
l'Hexagone mais chacun est dans sa
sphère quand on pourrait très bien
imaginer qu'on est dans chacun des
territoires peut-être à l'échelle de
chacune des intercommunalités une
obligation de réunir une conférence tous
les acteurs publics par un public qui
sont autour des sujets de la de la
problématique foncière
j'ai eu l'occasion récemment de
découvrir que
des communes n'ont aucun contact avec
leurs affaires aucun voilà or il s'avère
c'est un peu le sentiment qu'on a bon
ben il y a quand même des affaires
en notre mère qui je sais pas si les
propos sont enregistrés mais qui ont
donné plutôt la pression que on avance
et voilà il y avait il y avait il y a
une puissance d'ingénierie
d'accompagnement etc ça ça a de la
valeur si je puis dire en revanche on a
l'impression que cette valeur est sous
exploitée dans le sens où le dialogue
n'est pas instauré voilà et si on fait
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on s'amuse à un
sondage on fait un sondage de tous les
cadres où les élus intéressants qui
contactent avec sa safer
dernière chose
avec la problématique du foncier
agricole voilà en fait en outre-mer
comme dans l'Hexagone on se retrouve
avec en filigrane le sujet promis qui
est la valeur de ces fonciers tant que
le foncier est là c'est pour ça mais
peut-être à vous parlementaire de
rebousculer on sait bien que la
problématique du Zen nous renvoie des
problématiques fiscales etc mais là on a
un enjeu de la problématique de la
valeur du foncier et de la plus-value
qu'on peut réaliser quand il est rendu
constructible etc parce qu'aujourd'hui
un propriétaire uniquement sur le champ
financier voilà n'a intérêt qu'à faire
en sorte qu'ils deviennent
constructibles déclassé comme on dit
dans les territoires d'outre-mer tant
qu'on inverse pas ça que ce soit sur le
champ de la valeur environnementale d'un
terrain ou de sa valeur de production
agricole en fait on va avec des actions
publiques qui vont à l'encontre de la
logique de marché tant que c'est ça tant
que l'argent enfin bon voilà je et donc
ça c'est un problème qui n'est pas
spécifiquement ultra marin mais c'est
une question de fond qui se pose au fait
au parlementaire notamment mais c'est
pour nous c'est tout le modèle
tout le modèle économique de la
production de la ville etc qui est
questionnée autour de ça mais
aujourd'hui vous avez intérêt à ce que
votre terrain voilà la valeur d'un
terrain dépend de ce que je peux y
construire la valeur d'un terrain
aujourd'hui ne dépend pas de la valeur
sociale ou société
et donc ça c'est mon idée un peu
personnel je sors un petit peu du sujet
mais tant qu'on mettra pas les pieds
dans le plat sur ce sujet là on sera
toujours dans une logique de défense
défensive agricole alors qu'il faudrait
qu'on soit dans une logique de promotion
du foncier agricole
alors
les pieds dans le plat moi je suis assez
d'accord avec ça ça me va il ne s'agit
pas de tenter de concilier les
contraires à travers diverses réunions
ce qui m'intéresse si je parle
personnellement si je le dis
personnellement c'est que les toutes ces
réunions soient suivies d'acte
pragmatique et c'est là une réelle
problématique dans nos régions et sans
doute partout
mais de nombreuses réunions on décide on
acte les problèmes on décide d'avoir de
mettre en place un mode opératoire et
bien c'est comme si on faisait de la
recherche fondamentale et qu'on ne
l'appliquait pas donc moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les résultats au bout
d'un certain temps je dis que ça suffit
il y a trop de chômage trop d'avis
contraire trop de beaucoup de choses à
concilier et bien parlons en langage
franc et agissant merci
c'est quasiment le moins c'est quasiment
le mot de la fin et c'est
ton micro si tu veux
on peut dire mais si vous permettez pour
aller dans votre sens et là je sors un
peu du sujet mais ça ce soir
mais la question
de nous écouter et bien
si vous motorisez ça renvoie la question
de la propriété mais donc ça renvoie à
la question de la consistance de la
propriété et moi à titre personnel
complètement personnel je me dis que
dans un acte de propriété vous pourriez
avoir
un chapeau qui est de ma responsabilité
en tant que copropriétaire pour les
enjeux auxquels moi propriétaire je dois
pouvoir participer en substance de dire
j'ai mes responsabilités de fait parce
que je suis propriétaire que de
participer à la préservation de la
biodiversité à la gestion de l'eau aliex
etc et qu'au lieu d'avoir une puissance
publique qui par la règle en permanence
doit dire aux gens c'est de faire
rentrer un peu dans la constitution
allemande un article 14 on peut regarder
ça de près vous voyez qu'elle est trop
propriétaire c'est être propriétaire et
responsable par dans une logique de
copropriété parce que le fait d'être
propriétaire m'engage pour des sujets
qui sont au-delà de ma propriété ça
c'est les questions de fond mais je
souhaite bon courage si vous voulez
secouer la Constitution française
visiblement une bouteille à la mer pour
une possible révision constitutionnelle
donc rien n'est impossible visiblement
aujourd'hui et le champ est encore
visiblement encore ouvert on verra on
verra pendant combien de temps en tout
cas je voulais je voulais je voulais
vous remercier vous savez que le Sénat
et la chambre des collectivités et donc
je vais faire un peu de promotion quand
même parce qu'on l'a pas encore fait
pour le travail que vous avez fait ce
président avec vos équipes et je le mets
pour ceux qui nous regardent sur l'enjeu
du foncier en outre-mer qui date de
novembre 2022 je le dis parce que j'ai
beaucoup apprécié quand on s'est
rencontré et j'ai salué la qualité de
l'engagement et de la démarche et de la
profondeur de la démarche et du sérieux
et l'ex sécurité de celle-ci donc on a
aussi plaisir à dire quand ça fonctionne
pas aussi plaisir à dire qu'on ça
fonctionne donc là en l'occurrence
vraiment c'est un très très beau support
qui va de toute façon nous aider et vous
le voyez nous on pousse un petit peu
pour aller sur le foncière agricole
parce que c'est un sujet qui rejoint de
manière holistique je moi je suis tout à
fait en phase avec ce que vous dites sur
je suis propriétaire dit individuel mais
je m'inscris dans un tout collectif et
comment est-ce qu'on peut considérer les
deux et c'est pareil quand on approche
un abord d'un sujet il a forcément une
vision transversale à avoir qu'on a un
peu de mal et y compris dans les
services de l'État par exemple de
manière transversale ça n'est pas tout à
fait la nature des choses aujourd'hui
mais je pense que la société nous
poussera de toute façon aller vers ces
approches un peu plus globales en tout
cas merci pour la qualité de cette
audition soyez libre évidemment au-delà
de ces préconisations de nous faire
suivre des contributions que vous
jugerez nécessaires et notamment les
réponses aux questionnaires qu'on a
peut-être pas tout abordé et merci
également à nos collègues qui étaient en
présence ou à distance et je vous
souhaite une bonne fin de journée
oui bien sûr il y a aucune difficulté
merci bonne fin de journée au revoir